hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i am going to be reacting to a video by
the undead
kramet chronic talking about lana rhodes
was traumatized by the sex industry
before i start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
especially subscribe i'm trying to get
to 20 000 subscribers
and also ring the notification bell that
way you're gonna get
notifications for my videos every day
okay so here we go
one of my followers sent this to me on
instagram so if you guys want to submit
videos dm me on instagram
[Music]
hey guys it's undead chronic and rib of
the party frog
back again with another video this time
we'll respond i got a treat for ribby
ruby was very upset
very upset when i covered riley reed
the turbo salute of the millennium
getting married
to cuckus maximus in l.a i really really
really want to hop in on that roast he
was having his favorite sauce to roast
him because i i guess ruby really likes
roasting these ex adult industry
entertainers
is that it ribby well dude it's just
kind of like
their life is already a train wreck you
can't look away and ruby's showing up to
the train wreck like cronic and the boys
are there with the keg and he's like all
right boys
this is a hell of a wreck it's like a
50-car
pileup of phalluses ben up in this chick
and
we're cracking a couple open and we're
hanging out so yeah dude
the firefighters okay i get it could you
guys get to the empties
you guys up there i'll pull bodies from
the wreckage just like stand up and trip
over and puke
maybe we need one of these emts up here
i think my buddy overdosed
he's puking his lung out oh god now
we're responding to a video by a youtube
channel called
lana rhodes and 3g 1k clips which
i really don't want to know what's on
this channel i haven't checked it out
but i was sent this video and the title
is lana rhodes who's the chick on the
right
she's a uh yes adult
industry entertainer a sex worker i
don't want a
a a a corn star that's what we'll say a
corn star
we'll just use that for now a corn star
so she do a lot of black popcorn white
popcorn
multiple popcorns at the same time
different things getting popped inside
different orifices
and she's brutalized she's a victim
right and so she goes on this podcast
and complains about her
her job she complains about taking
shlong for money
and we got these two basic white bimbos
on the left in the middle
and look ruby called it out too like
they all have starbucks
of course they went dude they got
they're on their apple okay let's not
i love starbucks and i love apple
there's nothing wrong with liking a
quality brand
full computers god damn they're all
dolled up
and they got their starbucks coffee just
really living into the stereotype
leaning in there wholeheartedly oh my
god everything these everything these
females do
is is consumerism like look
all the big brands i guarantee you they
all have iphone
oh yeah there's one right there by your
coffee there's one yeah there's one
right here and i guarantee you both of
these
chicks have iphones y'all off max looks
in front of them
that you look does she has the chanel
butter i wonder what
about lana over here i wonder what she
spent all her porn checks on
dude i wonder how how deep lana could
get down on that mic
probably all the way to the laptop i
think she's about to tease the blonde on
the left um her technique
that's why she's looking at the mic with
their mouth to jump okay this is just
kind of
unnecessary i get it they're hoes can we
just react to the video
okay here we go both like an actual
lives at home it's definitely concerning
some kind of studio they shooting
well this could be a green screen behind
them i'm not sure we'll see if they
interact with it kind of looks like a
green spot
yeah anyhow let's let's let's roast them
a little bit enough let's see what
they're complaining about
i think ribby i'll give you a warning i
think uh they talk about her drinking
urine and
oh my god how can this turn like i could
not get off to this
i don't know who watches this too some
people have that fetish and it's crazy
and that's why they put it out
oh dude look at her neck
oh ah
oh she looks like an earthworm bro
looks like an earthworm put on a wig
dude that's not not a uh not a
flattering angle
this is i like how these guys are
roasting her but they're not showing
their face
like this girl talking look at how
orange she looks too
he's like she's like trump stole my luck
yeah basically dude that's definitely
definitely a natural hair color too
she's all all natural right there that's
her dress to the nines with makeup
you take that away this chick is as
natural as a taco bell
burrito yeah but sixty percent uh
i've actually said that i don't think
guys like a lot of like
fake tan fake nails fake eyelashes
like flavored meat flavor yeah okay
let's see out there because they're like
oh somebody will watch it which is
just like yeah offense but like that's
disgusting because obviously she's not
okay
yeah yeah other complaint oh my god dude
she looked like she had such a facelift
she got it pulled back so tight looks
like an
alien she looks like a she looks like a
survivor dude from pokemons
that's what we call in the industry okay
look i i agree with them like
they're the girls look fake um i'd say
they're pretty honestly but like i hear
what they're saying but i hate it when
guys just
roast women for no reason and i hate it
when girls do the same like we get it
can we move on crazy eyes she's got a
bad case of crazy eyes dude
jesus christ dude she has more than
crazy eyes this is a thousandth long
stare
this is worst bro she she looks like a
snake from dungeons and dragons
she looks like a survivor from pokemon
or like in ekkins
she looks like a demon a zinc succubus
bro
dude your eyeballs are like set really
high on your face
yeah and they're really far apart too i
wonder if that was you know
uh well i won't implicate anything let's
see so they talk they're complaining
about a a
an actress taking schlong too much in a
porn scene
you're like who wants to watch this i'll
tell you who wants to watch it
the incels that pay your budget and
i mean to me it's just it really makes
me sad because i think of the girl and i
think wow like
i can just see in her eyes that she did
not want to do the scene
but she's doing it because of the
reasons of you know she needs the money
or this is a flex
dude she's not even looking at them are
you reading a script you're just staring
she's not making eye contact speaking to
them she's showing she's watching some
she's watching a porn video
of some girl oh
of a gang activity right and so she's
saying
i look at her eyes i think she's in
situation because she needs money okay
here's a news flash for you chick guess
what
when a dude needs money he doesn't have
to have sex
for about 30 minutes and walk away with
hundreds of dollars we don't have that
option
now we got to break our bodies for like
20 30 bucks an hour
at that look at all these dudes working
in fast food getting paid [ __ ] wages
look at all these dudes working
construction they don't have the option
to to lay down take schlong
and have enough money to feed themselves
for a week
i agree with this actually a lot of
women
complaining about the repercussions of
like doing these sexual acts
they complain after they receive the
benefits of them
and it the oh no i wish i didn't do that
after you built your whole career on
porn and now can make millions of
dollars being an influencer every year
it seems a bit
and genuine these people who are doing
sex work they want a lot of money easily
they don't want to work hard they want
to do the least amount of work as
possible
because having sex is not a lot of
physical labor i don't care what you say
i don't go but this is what happens
women sign up for this stuff and don't
realize the repercussions
that they're signing up for like they
might think it's about like
that they've heard it's a bad idea that
it's stigmatized but there's a lot of
bad information given to women
so a lot of these girls sign up for this
stuff
and then don't realize how bad
like mentally that is on your like mind
body and soul
until after you know what i had to do in
high school ruby
i had to work a jackhammer out in
[ __ ] atlanta
she was a hot summer son i feel
oh yeah it's brutal dude the dudes who
do that for a living
they can't use their arms by the time
they're like 40 45 the nerves because
all the vibrations it kills the nerves
in their forearms and hands
yeah they don't make it they don't make
half the money
these stupid female sex industry workers
make
and they're telling me they feel bad
because she she doesn't want to do that
well here's the thing chronix you wanted
the
resources and easy money right now
without any of the
judgment of that's a piece of history
when something's on the internet
it'll be there until the day she dies
till after she dies people will be
watching that in the future
that is her legacy is taken
on the internet for money so she liked
the money up front but afterwards
if you know chicks when you hit a
certain age maybe she wanted a
beta boy for a boyfriend people weren't
having it maybe she wanted to do
something else outside
the industry most people aren't going to
hire you so yeah now she decides to
[ __ ] about it because
she don't want to deal with the
consequences riley
and yeah this is i agree with them like
if you want to do
porn and sex work and you think the cost
of your mind body and soul
is okay who am i to stop you right i
i can't stop you but
people aren't going to feel sympathy for
you
when you chose that life and these are
the consequences you read
lana rhodes and mia khalifa
a hundred years from now their legacy
their legacy will be taking
long online
nothing more nothing less that's it
to be fair most people don't know you
who you are a hundred
years from now like i have no idea who
my great great
great grandma her grandpa was i know
my grandma my grandpa and like my first
grandparents i don't even know much
about my great-grandparents yeah you've
permanently marked yourself
as being a e-whore with the rest
of eternity congratulations i hope
selling your soul
was worth it but let's hear lana talk
yeah i agree and that's what a lot of
girls don't realize until it's
too late and i have a little bit more
empathy
um towards young women that are put in
that situation or two i should say
choose that situation because
a lot of women are given bad advice from
older women
and a lot of women um
don't really understand how bad the
consequences are going to be like
they might think oh um
you know it like people are going to
call me a [ __ ] so what but they
don't realize the long-term
repercussions of what they're signing up
for until it's really too late
um so yeah i agree with what they're
saying breaking drinking urine flexible
job for her right now
she was convinced she was pressured you
know she was manipulated into doing this
by her agent because he
you know told her like it's either this
way or
the highway like i can't even imagine
how that girl felt having to do
something that she clearly
does not want to do like there this is
not acting like she's full-blown
she should just go up to any like fry
cook in america and ask him
how does it feel to do something you
don't want to do
is this peak woman logic but this is
what men don't understand
women when they have sex are giving away
a piece of their soul every single time
they do it and it's a lot harder
emotionally on a woman than it is a guy
and when at a young age you're given
the decision when your brain isn't even
fully formed
to do i mean do porn right i mean
luckily i had like parents that would
never have let that happen even when i
was 18.
but like i could see why some girls
you know accept that lifestyle
especially at a young age
because
men aren't but that's the thing men
aren't going to be sympathetic to you
because they're like
i have had to work this job that job and
that job and you guys just
get to have sex but it's really not just
having sex it's really selling a piece
of your soul
yeah well dude at the same time you talk
about a fry cook
nobody had a gun to her head she could
have at any point
um hey i want to do this not for me
walked out and she wouldn't have gotten
paid
but they wouldn't have kept her there
she had the right to do that she could
get another job be a waitress be a
freaking
but after one or two i bet she felt like
she was trapped
and i bet she felt like she had to i
mean
i'm not i'm not trying to defend what
she did i definitely
there are repercussions for what you
choose to do and these are the
consequences that she's left with
but um
i just you know i feel sad for young
girls that choose that
like the repercussions are hard uber
driver do anything
but she didn't want to do that because
she wanted more money quick
and that was the easiest way to do it
again i don't feel bad for these women
oh they're victims why are they victims
they're chosen
unless you because they regret you can
show me that they were forcibly
put into the sex industry at the point
of a gun or someone who like you know
some
pimp then they're not victims and don't
say the victims because you're taking
away from the actual victims who don't
have a choice
yeah i agree with this i they're
definitely she's definitely not a victim
but i can extend my
sympathy to her if that makes sense okay
because there are there are women out
there and men
and children who don't have a choice and
so when giga horse
like lana rhodes over here tries to
paint herself as a victim
she takes away from actual victims that
don't have a choice
in being abused in gang activities
it's just it's it's disgusting you're
not a victim you are
like a disease-ridden pit crying
you know like i there's just no way
she's acting and enjoying this so
yeah i've had friends who have been
choked
out so much that they've actually passed
out during a scene
and there's really and they stayed in
the industry
they just like crazy stuff going on that
damages people's bodies for the rest of
their lives
wait you're saying that getting brutally
copulated with by by a bunch of
men who have been selected for having
large members who want to treat you in a
degrading manner for the video
you're saying that affects you
permanently
it that sounds like a red pill i mean
that just
what having having sex changes you
physically for the rest of your life
oh okay yeah i'm okay i agree i agree
lon i don't disagree with that point
well
chronic and just i'm not an expert on
this but
like i'm pretty sure they know that
for legal reasons they have a lot of
paperwork you have to fill out
you understand that in this scene you're
gonna have x y and z done to you
yes sign here there's a lot of
um you don't just like hey wanna do some
movies and then ah this is making me so
uncomfortable i hate
the like i i do not
like the idea of porn and isn't it true
that 90 percent
of women in the porn industry were like
sexually abused as a kid
let me know in the comments if that stat
is true or false boom you do it that day
like you got to get permission they're
like you can say i mean
that's how it works at chronic studios
yeah you know what you know what they're
getting in for it you have to sign a lot
of papers you have to agree to it
so for her to act like oh i'm a victim
they pressured me into it
again unless they physically made you do
it which they didn't
that's bs it's kind of like buyer beware
hey ruby would you get choked out for
twenty thousand dollars
uh yeah probably i would
let's be honest hey if if he would would
you guys get choked out for twenty
thousand not just
just choke that that's it but uh it
could be by dude but ideally it would be
built by uh
yeah woman with like some real curvy
legs
and just wrap them around your neck and
choke you out that way buried between
the thighs
but uh you know how about lady uh
demotrov whatever it is
oh yeah dude smother between the tatas
that'll be a nice way to hack
yeah yeah so um again getting paid
twenty thousand dollars to get choked
out is still a good deal to a lot of
people so
stop complaining about it i likely don't
have any issues
but i've seen scenes shot in europe
where guys are literally
punching into a girl's [ __ ] like
terrible punched like a chick okay
i'm not even gonna comment on you dirty
europeans i got no comment about this
this is so
nasty this i'm like she's going to have
issues for the rest of her life
due to this oh my god i want to puke
that's so gross
do you guys watch this is it worth
someone making
a little bit of money and someone
jerking off to it
uh again there's men out there but
that's your that's who pays your bills
even now i bet with her influencer stuff
who do professions that will give them
cancer that will kill them
20 years early and you're not no one
cares about them
so dude it's like she's complaining
about taking slong
as as a corn star that's like a
firefighter being like man
a lot of those buildings we've been
running into are really hot
but i don't think she's really
complaining about it in that way i think
she's just educating people on the
negative repercussions that come from
porn
because i do think it's really important
for porn stars
to warn young girls about the negative
repercussions that happen from porn
both physically and mentally it's like
yeah it's like yeah dude that's kind of
that's man i'm sick of sweating dude i'm
still putting on all this stuff
running around yeah i want to sit at a
desk all day
yeah dude you gotta know what you're
signing up for
yeah well you know what let's let's get
to let's get to the the great part where
she talks about you know her favorite
scenes
and during the scene he asked me to
drink it and i didn't know how to say no
it was one of the most disgusting foul
scenes
i ever had to do i actually
do think a lot of women would benefit
from agreeable
or like um what is it called
assertiveness training
because i know okay not
i have not done porn or been in any like
crazy situations like that
but i empathize with women like who
don't
know how to say no because a lot of
women tend to be higher on the
agreeableness scale so even when they
want to say no they don't
and i'm telling a therapist this and
they don't even [ __ ] know what to say
to me
yeah no one can can you imagine being
this cheap
she's just like i was asked to drink a
pee
and i didn't know how to say no it's
true
i'd be sitting there just writing well
because i'm sure she felt like she had
to because they were paying her
like or like maybe it was a big scene i
don't know i'm trying to be empathetic
i'm an empathetic person
down notes furiously you know why i'd be
like god damn it
i'm gonna get a noble peace prize off
this [ __ ]
dude i would be just laughing in your
face i would have all the characters
i'd be interviewing her from every angle
i'd be like tell me all the details
oh my god you know what you could
package her and sell her just some giga
cuck
dude that that is someone's daughter how
well what'd you do at work today honey
well you know i funneled
uh eight men's eight different men's
urine down my tract
that's like a typical day for this broad
oh my god dude
this is despite how good she might look
and what those jeans might reflect her
jeans also let her down the path of
being a giga
gig a sleuth but like oh yeah she's
disgusting to me on every level
damn it's good not even good it's like
damaged
uh it's like a damaged grenade that
might go off when you try to throw it
i mean but uh let's
let's give her another 10 seconds you
can relate like no one [ __ ] knows
what to say about it
and so
let's just ruby i don't know what to say
can we end it please remy please
oh my gosh yeah dude if you guys want to
support the content okay i'm going to
end this now too
because i think that's their outro i i
agree with them
like women have the opportunity to get
nailed
why am i doing quotation marks to get
nailed for money
and they don't a lot of times want to
deal with the repercussions of it which
includes
everything these guys were saying um
i'm like i believe in forgiveness i
believe in redemption
so and i believe people can be more than
like their past
but yeah that's probably what she's
going to be known for forever
that is a consequence that she has but
anyways let me know in the comments if
you if you are a girl because most of my
subscribers are men would you
do something like that and would you
think it was worth it and do not forget
to
subscribe to the channel and ring the
notification bell